foreign
and welcome back to Simply learns
YouTube channel kaushal decide and I
hope you guys are doing well in this
video we are going to take you through
an interesting AI tool which can help
you in different ways the flare AI we
are going to discuss and this AI can
help you create your own advertisement I
mean if you own a product or if you want
to advertise something then this tool is
the go-to option for you and we are
going to see how to use this tool is
this particular video but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these videos
and if you find them interesting then
subscribe to Simply learns YouTube
channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply log
we all know that AI is expanding at a
very rapid Pace chair GPT is a great
example
so in this time begging a job in this
field is super beneficial because of
course it offers great salary packages
and AI is interesting as we all know so
on that note we present to you the
simply learns post graduate program in
Ai and machine learning in collaboration
with Purdue University boost your career
with this Ai and ml course delivered in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM you can learn in-demand skills such
as machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and many more you'll receive a
prestigious certificate and ask me
anything session by IBM with five
capstones in different domain using real
data sets you will gain practical
experience as well master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts ensure
top-notch education simply learns job
assist helps you get noticed by Leading
companies so this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural
networks computer vision Gans Keras
tensorflow and many more skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunities the link
is mentioned in the description box
below so let's begin with flair AI what
we have to do first is we have to go to
Google and just write here player
AI when so this is the first option you
will get click on it flare so this is
the interface of play area the AI design
tool for Branded content so it can help
you with your brand
definitely you will get better reach
because
what usually happens is
we use different tools like Adobe
Photoshop and other tools to just show a
brand item in different ways but with
this AI tool we can use this and it's
not time consuming as well so let's
start what we'll do is we'll write here
create with layer so here you can see we
have a demo a demo video basically so
here you can see we have a product a
perfume bottle and here we have
different items or we can say different
options we can generate we can customize
and that's it just right here click
generate it will generate a beautiful
image for you so let's start or if you
want to watch the video here's the video
so here you can see this image turned
into that so we don't have to do much of
editing everything was done by AI so
let's see how we can do it so we'll
click on create with Flare now continue
with Google
so you will have to login
although it's free to use this AI tool
is completely free so here we are we are
going to click on create new project so
here you can see we have
a box for placing our product here so
let's say we are placing something out
of here fine so here you can see we have
a Starbucks coffee let's place it in the
middle so generated image images will
appear here see here you can see
generated images will appear here it's
written now click on generate what you
want to do so here you can see we have
different templates fine we have this
template we can use this we can use any
of them
so let's use
this one fine
and click on this click on generate
so paper cup on a rock surrounded by
trees in front of Canyon and River fine
so here you can see it's still
progressing and now here you can see we
have a coffee mug present over here
Starbucks coffee if I zoom in for you a
little bit
so here you can see how nice it's
looking it's not even looking like that
this cup is edited it's looking like
that this cup is actually placed there
so another way if you want to do the
same thing what we have to do is we have
to use Adobe Photoshop we have to use
different tools right but here you can
see how detailed it is we have shadows
for the cup as well not just that but if
you
click here on generate and if you will
find the mirror one you will get to see
the
reflection completely so if I click here
paper cup on a wet surface surrounded by
rain in front of Spotlight and strong
Shadows so it's pretty good we'll copy
it as well we'll need it later on I'll
tell you why we need while we'll need it
so here you can see the
it's good right so you here you can see
and
here you can see we have a image the
paper cup what it said paper cup on a
wet surface the surface is wet
surrounded by rain so here you can see
rain
in front of a spotlight and strong
shadows in front of Spotlight and strong
Shadow so here you can see the shadow of
a
paper cup fine similarly we can use
different tools we have different
elements as well like if you want to use
for example if you go on humans if you
want to use we have a
hand thing so here you can see if you
want to put it here and if you want to
bring it to the front so here you can
see it's
on a hand so here you can see how we can
use this tool fine so we have a number
of options available here if I if we'll
go to a set so here you can see we have
a perfume bottle as well we'll delete
this one
will use a perfume bottle it's from
Chanel and now what we are going to do
is we are going to delete them as well
now what we are going to do is we are
going to generate something else fine so
now we are going to use the editor so
here you can see we have a product which
is a perfume bottle so we have to edit
the prompt in the form below fine the
product is a perfume bottle then we have
a placement where we want to place it
on a mirror
or here you can see we have different
options so let's say we are using wooden
surface surrounded by
surrounded by let's say flowers fine now
create this image in your mind we have a
perfume bottle which is present on a
wooden surface its placement is on a
wooden surface and it is surrounded by
flowers fine now number of results how
many number of results you want I'll
make it extra strong extra strong color
strength and outline strength just to
show you guys how it looks now click on
generate and wait for few seconds not
even minutes but it will be done in few
seconds here you can see how fast this
AI is so this AI tool is very useful if
you have your own brand if you have your
own products not services but product so
here you can see it's present on a
wooden surface and we have flowers on it
fine so what we'll do is we'll write
here next to
orange fine
generate its tote it totally depends on
your creativity how you want to create
your image how you want to present your
brand service or your brand product so
you can see we are done with almost 85
percent we have to wait for few more
seconds not even a minute as I already
mentioned and it will be done so here
you can see it's present on a
wooden surface
and orange is not there
basically what we have to do is we have
to go to generate we have to use
something else then
we'll use
elements fine let's see if it works or
not perfume bottle on a wooden surface
next to almonds in front of Spotlight
and strong shadow okay we are not going
to use this
what we are going to do is
nature in the background let's see
how it looks wait for few more seconds
and again it will give you an AI
generated image which will be present on
a wooden surface next to almonds in
front of nature in the background now
here you can see we have a wooden
surface we have almonds present over
here and we have nature behind it wow it
looks it looks fine not that good so
what we'll do next is we'll write here
circular glass platform
and we'll write here next to
a mug
we are not going to use jungle we are
going to use orange sunset in the
background maybe it will look better
because sunsets are always beautiful so
let's see how it comes out so here we
have
the output so it's present on a circular
glass platform okay it's fine we have a
mug
okay the mug is not visible
or maybe this is the mug it's
not that good and then we have the
sunset so Sunset is here here you can
see now the image looks real that's the
point it's not something that's that
looks like that it's edited or it's just
cropped from somewhere and put it over
there no it looks real fine right it has
the shadows and all the edges and
saturation it's changed as per the
background so right now the background
is sunset so here you can see the orange
lights here present over here fine
so that's how you can use this tool to
create an advertisement for your brand
product now the next thing is not just
that but it allows you to upload your
own pictures so it's quite interesting
let me just delete all of them
so what you have to do is you have to
download the picture of your product
upload it from here
and we have a product of an iPhone so
here I have this picture
okay so I'll skip this for now because
I'm going to show you if I write here
let's say it's an iPhone
done
now
here you can see we have a product
placed here so here you can see we have
a background right we have blue and
white this base as well
first thing we are going to do is we are
going to click on that we are going to
click on edit now the best part is we
can remove this background and it turns
out to be so good let's check it out so
click on remove background it will take
few seconds to remove all this from your
background and you'll notice something
that the background the edges of the
phone
how nicely it has done it so here you
can see there's nothing wrong and every
Edge is perfectly fine right the
background is completely removed now now
what we have to do is we have to
generate a image so we have an iPhone we
want it to be present at a circular
glass
platform we will
golden sparkles in front of
let's remove it and see what else we
have
desert in the background let's try this
generate it and it will again take few
seconds
so are you guys ready to check out an
iPhone present in the desert
so basically the idea of this AI tool is
it saves a lot of time for anyone right
so here you can see
the iPhone is present in a circular
glass platform right
and we have
what else we had
okay we had golden sparkles golden
sparkles are here somewhere
and we have a desert in the background
so desert here you can see we have a
desert
now what we'll do is we'll write here
mirror
and we want it to be present in
water
and droplets
fine so let's try it I haven't tried it
either till now so it will take some
time the iPhone will be placed on water
with some droplets surrounding it and
the background will be okay a mirror so
it looks good right so here you can see
the shadow actually the shadow of the
phone how realistic it looks so this is
how you can use this AI tool and not
just that but you can download your
images
so here you can see click on download
image and done the image is downloaded
and just click you have from this to
this and it totally depends on your
creativity how you want to present your
brand product so that's all for this
video guys if you enjoyed watching this
video then do give it a thumbs up and if
you want to know more about such AI
tools then do let us know in the comment
section below because we will definitely
answer your doubts or we'll bring more
AI tools if you guys want so that's all
for this video guys we'll see you next
time until then keep learning and stay
tuned to Simply learn thank you staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you